[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est parti pour une
nouvelle édition deux points de vue vous
allez découvrir dans un instant nos
invités de jeunes recrues des habitués
vous allez voir tout ça mais d'abord
notre sommaire en images les gilet jaune
suite et sans doute pas fin
la question du jour c'est de savoir si
une tentative va être faite de
désamorcer la crise d'ici samedi
ou si au contraire rien bougez gilet
jaune ras-le-bol fiscale colère sociale
ce sont aussi les ingrédients des
élections européennes un scrutin qui
sera évidemment cruciale pour la suite
du quinquennat emmanuel macron le
prépare donc activement un dîner secret
à lui lieu mardi à l'elysée vous verrez
il y avait des poids lourds du paysage
politique autour de la table tout autre
sujet mais qui peut devenir très
politique c'est celui de ce gros couac
entre la france et l'italie le sujet
n'ont pas les migrants mais plutôt un
migrant de la renaissance léonard de
vinci
le motif de la polémique l'italie ne
veut plus prêter d'oeuvres du peintre
pour la grande exposition prévue au
louvre l'an prochain enfin thème
toujours très sensible celui de la
justice des mineurs la garde des sceaux
vient d'annoncer une réforme prenant
tout le monde de court une réforme pour
quoi faire
faut-il durcir les textes vous nous
donnerez votre avis bonjour agathe kg
mon cher si nous avoir rejoints vous
avez travaillé avec benoît hamon d'abord
quand il était ministre de l'éducation
nationale puis ensuite pour sa campagne
présidentielle
depuis vous présidez une agence de
communication de conseil en stratégie de
conseil en stratégie ainsi qu'un film
tant qu'ils s'appellent cartes sur table
merci d'être avec nous aussi
bernard de la villardière vous êtes
journaliste présentateur d'émissions
d'investigation vous êtes aussi l'auteur
de l'homme qui marche
non pas que vous soyez en marche mais il
s'agit de votre expérience de retour sur
le terrain comme journaliste bonjour
j'ai ce matelas nous avoir rejoints vous
êtes aujourd'hui directeur de cabinet du
maire de nanterre nanterre une petite
ville de 80
quinze mille habitants dans les
hauts-de-seine auparavant vous exerciez
la même fonction à saint denis une autre
petite ville votre engagement communiste
vous l'aviez débuté professionnellement
à l'humanité comme journaliste puis
comme conseiller au cabinet de marie
george buffet marie george buffet
ministre des sports lors de la coupe du
monde de 98 boeing bons souvenirs
bonjour marc landré rédacteur en chef du
service économie france du figaro alors
les gilet jaune l'agenda social la
fiscalité tout ça ça vous connaît ce
sont vos meilleurs amis
tout comme le tennis parce que vous le
rappeliez demain c'est la finale de ces
le début de la finale la coulisse à
lille
et voilà ne pas rater pour un doublé
historique exactement je ne sais pas si
on en parlera on commence par les jets
jaune alors voici les éléments du jour
sur le dossier
d'abord cette porte de sortie proposé
par françois bayrou
il dit qu'il faudrait peut-être songer à
remplacer la taxe prévue par une taxe
flottante dépendante du coût du baril
regardez la phrase du président du modem
elle s'affiche à l'écran elle est
extrait de son interview ce matin dans
le figaro
alors l'idée de cette taxe flottante
elle a été aussitôt retoqué par un
membre du gouvernement en l'espèce le
ministre des collectivités territoriales
sébastien lecornu qui était ce matin
l'invitée des rep c'est en l'écoutant
aménagement de la hausse oui ou non pour
moi
non non non pas d'aménagements n'ont osé
pas par brutalité ou ailleurs mais je
sais juste que donc long des mois n'est
pas où je vais vous dire autrement le
débat n'est pas ouverte sur
l'aménagement de la hausse ni présent la
république ni pour les scores mais en
tant que ministre et moi aussi dans ma
sensibilité
oui je pense que soient ensemble ce pays
maintenant soit je sais très bien qu'ils
veulent faire et quand on va le faire
donc taxe flottante a priori non une
autre idée fait son chemin c'est celle
de laurent berger secrétaire général de
la cfdt qui veut réunir tout le monde
autour de la table pour ce qu'il appelle
un pacte social de la conversion
écologique
alors va essayer d'y voir un peu clair
dans tout ça marque on sent que ça
cogite de tout côté que depuis edouard
philippe sur france 2 dimanche dernier
droit dans ses bottes on va pas
pas bougé il s'est passé des choses il
ya un peu de fébrilité à la proche de
samedi de la fébrilité parce qu'on ne
sait absolument pas comment ça va se
passer samedi mais surtout l'exécutif se
rend compte que quoi qu'ils fassent ça
changera rien aujourd'hui vous avez une
révolte et gilet jaune qui est tellement
hétéroclite qui a tellement de
revendications qui dépasse largement la
question de la fiscalité écolo qu'ils
peuvent prendre n'importe quelle mesure
justement sur cette fiscalité écolo sur
son poids dans les prix des carburants 1
c'est inaudible de te servir à rien vous
avez entendu dans les manifestations
entre ce qu'ils veulent je suis et je
reste poli faire démissionner macron
ceux qui veulent remettre lisf vous avez
tout et n'importe quoi
les pour le pouvoir d'achat pour les
plantes enfin tout et n'importe quoi j
le match à nantes je crois pas du tout
je pense que si françois bayrou a fait
cette proposition d'essayer d'une sortie
de crise je crois que c'est parce que il
mesure parce qu'il connaît le terrain
c'est un élu local
il mesure sans doute mieux que ceux qui
sont au gouvernement
il mesure mieux à quel point ce
mouvement est profondément ancré dans la
population et le sondage qui est sorti
hier a dû faire l'effet d'une douche
froide à l'elysée à matignon parce que
sans doute espère est il qu'à qu'en
dramatisant la situation en montrant des
images de violence
le mouvement allait être décrochée dans
le dos l'opinion publique ce n'est
absolument pas ce qui se passe 70% des
français qui sont encore qui soutiennent
le mouvement
et donc on voit bien plus forte adhésion
on va justement pas les sondages on a on
a on a un sondage demain dans le figaro
sondage hebdomadaire de sao doxa dentsu
consulting et ben ça conforte ce que
vous dites
les français sont plus nombreux à
estimer que le mouvement justifié +3
points par rapport à la semaine dernière
et autres proportions très forte deux
tiers d'entre eux 70% donc 10
il faut que le mouvement se poursuive
parce que la force de ce mouvement c'est
la parole des de ceux qui le portent
site c'est quand vous voyez quand vous
voyez les images et quand vous entendez
les témoignages une femme qui dit je vis
seule avec mes deux enfants et les 950
euros par mois quand vous entendez une
retraitée dire comment je ferais
monsieur le président de la république
avec 800 euros par mois
ça c'est la force de la vérité ce sont
des mots juste sincère
les français se reconnaissent et par
force de la vérité j'ai le statut vous
allez peut-être pas forcément être
d'accord bernard je veux dire que moi je
comprends pas grand chose à ce moment et
j'ai entendu tout et son contraire la
france des villes contre la france des
campagnes la france des périphéries la
france est exposée contre la france
planqué la france d'être ailleurs pour
entre les élites et les élus je veux
dire que j'ai personnellement j'ai passé
mais il traduit quelque chose dans ce
match
oui oui bien sûr mais des 77 % cc c'est
très hétéroclite ce sont des gens qui
pensent pas forcément la même chose
ils sont pour le mouvement parce qu'ils
ont envie de râler mais ils sont pas
unis ils sont pas sur un solide
programme aille même position l'accueil
67% ce ne sont pas des anti macron ce
sont des gens qui au delà de macron
déteste la fiscalité ou trouve qu'il n'a
pas assez qui a passé des tas d'autres
qui sont qui pense qu'elle a beaucoup
qui potro d'état au lait ou par quatre
sur un mouvement de gaulois réfractaires
aux mouvements de contestataires par
plaisir de compter ses je pense au
contraire il ya une vraie cohérence dans
ce mouvement c'est un mouvement en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat des plus
modestes et s'il ya 77 % des français
qui soutiennent ce mouvement c'est parce
qu'il ya une grande part des français
qui ont bien conscience qu'il ya un
problème de pouvoir d'achat chez les
plus modestes un problème de pouvoir
d'achat qui est mesuré de manière
extrêmement claire quand vous voyez les
projections que fait l'institut des
politiques publiques pour 2019 sur le
mouvement du pouvoir d'achat le
mouvement du pouvoir d'achat en 2019
pour les plus modestes ce sera une
diminution
par contre pour les 1% les plus riches
on s'oriente vers une augmentation de 6%
du pouvoir d'achat une augmentation de
1% du pouvoir d'achat des 0 1% les plus
riches donc ce que dit ce mouvement
c'est les plus modestes ne s'en sortent
plus et ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat être
raboteur 2018 et pressent que le poids
leur pouvoir d'achat va être rabotées en
2019 alors même qu'on a une explosion
des inégalités dans ce pays et c'est là
où est la cohérence de ce mouvement
alors bien sûr après on peut aller
prendre des panneaux qui demandent de
faire tomber la tête du roi où on peut
entendre les gilet jaune qui devant les
caméras s'amuse à chanter macron
démission certains sont pour plus et à
d'autres pour un peu moins d'état
peut-être parce qu'ils ont des solutions
politiques différentes
ce qui est plutôt sain
par contre il ya une vraie prise de
conscience que le pouvoir d'achat des
plus modestes ne peut pas continuer à
diminuer sinon ce pays va vers
l'explosion et c'est ça la menace
derrière le mouvement des idées je est
un autre aspect marque qui est soulevée
d'ailleurs par un sondage ipsos qui
parle dans le monde ce soir face à
l'après midi qui dit le consentement à
l'impôt des français il est de plus en
plus réduits on est à une très faible
majorité des 54 % mais moi qui dis oui
la peau est justifié on est parti d'un
acte civique un acte citoyen nommé ceci
dit les citoyens il ya quand même 56 %
des foyers fiscaux qui payent pas
l'impôt sur le revenu donc et quand vous
regardez notamment sur les gens étaient
un peu des taxes indirectes n'était pas
l'impôt sur le revenu voilà tout le
monde paye la tva d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs probablement à l'impôt le
plus injuste parce que tout le monde
paye à due proportion quel que soit ses
niveaux de revenus contrairement à
l'impôt sur le revenu qui lui est
proportionnel mais c'est comme quand on
demandait sur la taxe d'habitation est
ce que les français sont pour ou contre
la suppression des taxes d'habitation
généralement c'est ce qu'il appelle qui
sont pour sa suppression mais c'est pas
ce qu'ils vont véritablement bénéficier
donc on est tous et je veux dire rien
nouveau vous demandez aux français ce
que vous voulez payer plus d'impôts je
connais peu de gens même masochiste qui
vont répondre oui en revanche la plupart
font pour la suppression la perte de
confiance dans la perte de confiance
dans l'impôt et plus généralement dans
l'état elle elle et elle s'explique en
grande partie par l'injustice le
sentiment d'injustice sociale c'est à
dire que tout le monde n'est pas au même
niveau là en l'occurrence on applique le
principe pollueur payeur mais on
l'appliquent pas pour tout le monde
par exemple souvent les c'est le
kérosène il est pas taxer les premiers
le premier émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre en france c'est qui c'est pas les
conducteurs de voitures diesel le
premier émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
en france c'est le groupe total dix
neuvième au monde premier en france en
2010 est le groupe total a réalisé 8
milliard et demi de dollars de bénéfices
natale par
les qui fait du carburant aussi oui oui
de sur ces 8 milliards et demi
pas un centime pour la transition
écologique à les gens quand les gens
n'ont fait de me défoncer pour l'énergie
mais aujourd'hui dont l'âge est là
aujourd'hui je défendrai leuthard a
gagné ou pas caricaturer les choses à ce
point et puis quand on 18 milliards
d'euros de bénéfices sont de bénéfices
qu'il fait pour la plupart à l'étranger
il faut pas oublier que à la pompe quoi
les distributeurs de carburant égaux a
rien de certain
paris deux quads injustice l'injustice
face à ces mesures c'est aussi le fait
que le kérosène ne rentre pas dans le
dans les carburants qui sont taxés ça de
plus en plus de gens le disent
l'injustice et le fait qu'il y a
toujours la dispense fiscale à l'égard
du du ce qu'on appelle le gazole
professionnel c'est-à-dire les voulez
des poids lourds non mais qu'on ne dise
comme si vous voulez le sentiment
d'aider des français qui eux voient
qu'ils payent de plus en plus chers ils
se disent on est pas tous on n'est pas
tous pareils devant c'est écolo qui a
été lancée sous françois hollande était
prix du pétrole baissaient personnes est
allée se plaindre qu'on allait taxer
pour l'heure en matière de transition
écolo qu'on allait me taxer de diesel et
qu'on allait rapprocher la taxation du
zèle son adolescence tout simplement
parce que les prix du pétrole bessan on
avait une baisse des prix à la pompe là
le problème c'est qu'on a eu un effet
ciseau qui fait que les prix du pétrole
ayant augmenté
et ça c'est sont des cours mondiaux dont
la france n'est pas redevable
elle est obligée de les appliquer à la
pompe aujourd'hui vous avez la double
peine qui a été et est encore sa baisse
depuis maintenant 15 jours
la double peine de l'augmentation des
prix du pétrole qui se répercute dans
les prix plus une petite augmentation ou
petite augmentation de la fiscalité
colonne augmentation des prix de
l'essence liées à la fiscalité ça
représente un tiers de l'augmentation
donc c'est une part qui est comme une
part significative et là j'ai le
sentiment d'injustice par rapport à
l'impôt des français
c'est un sentiment qui est pas seulement
fantasmes et c'est une réalité qu'on
voit finalement qui a énormément
d'impôts que les français et notamment
les taxes indirectes qui sont totalement
et autres distributive dans un contexte
le global on a imposé aux français une
suppression de l' isf pour rêver qu'on a
un vrai c'était dans un programme
présidentiel que
personne qui a gagné l'or les français
ont vu la suppression isf et en même
temps on veut un rabot de 5 euros sur
les affaires il ya un problème de
cohérence dans la politique qui est
menée c'est à dire une politique en
faveur en matière d'exécution la taxe
d'habitation ou la suppression des
cotisations sociales politiques ou les
salariés notamment à nous garantir le
pouvoir d'achat des faits une petite
cause petite pause bernard pour donner
la parole à nos internautes s'il vous
plaît alors d'abord cij qui nous dit
l'écologie est juste m'excuser pour
mieux augmenter les impôts anti mac il
s'agit d'une overdose d'impôts et taxes
rejoint ce qu'on disait sur le
consentement à l'impôt r34 le
gouvernement ne reculera pas car ils ont
trop claironner qu'ils ne bougeront pas
nicole ajoute pour moi non seulement la
voiture est indispensable mais
obligatoire qu'elle n'est pas transports
en commun et cab ronito tout le monde et
pour l'impôt quand les autres le paye
alors on a compris que vous mettra pas
d'ailleurs je dois apporter la taxe
énergétique ou la taxe carbone il y en a
20 pour ça ça me manque qui vont être
utilisés pour la transition énergétique
est l'entraînement car les caisses de
l'état mais il faut que je le rappeler
mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait un
glissement dans l'est dans l'explication
de cette hausse des taxes non pas le
bruit après la transition énergétique ce
fait rêver par la police
les gens souffrent et ils ont besoin
d'avoir des réponses à leurs solutions
et la vie de tous les jours il ya eu 9
millions de pauvres en france et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui voient là qu'ils
ont du mal y compris et des artisans des
agriculteurs des travailleurs qui ont du
mal à boucler leurs fins de mois et ça
c'est plus que la justice sociale je
crois que c'est leur situation à la fin
du mois et c'est leur situation c'est la
vie quotidienne qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y comprennent plus rien et ils en
ont ras-le-bol il ya un phénomène de
ras-le-bol dans les faits la proposition
de laurent berger mettre tout le monde
autour d'une table avec le terme qu'il
emploie de pacte social de la conversion
fcc encore possibilités où plus personne
n'y croit
de bonnes idées nous dira qu'il peut pas
y avoir d'écologie sans justice sociale
ça ne marche pas ça n'a aucune chance de
marcher on peut pas demander l'adhésion
de tout un peuple à la transition
écologique et prendre des mesures qui
soient uniquement des mesures punitives
sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est pas possible ça ne marche pas donc
oui il faut que l'écologie s'accompagne
de la justice sociale ça recouvre parce
que concrètement marx est pas sans
forcément rentrer dans des détails mais
c'est un peu comme qu'on sait c'est leur
faire un grenelle de l'environnement
mais tout autour de la table on
réfléchit à comment mieux accompagner
une fiscalité écolo que l'on peut y
avoir des traductions concrètes
oui sur l'accompagnement dead de l'ours
est ce que c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement improprement mal expliqué
peut-être pas assez suffisamment mais
c'est exactement la même chose sauf que
ce que prône laurent berger et en ce
sens je pense qu'il a raison c'est que
de trouver un consensus
ça peut faire ça peut améliorer
l'acceptabilité sociale d'une réforme là
le fait est qu'il leur est soigné le
coeur soigner le drame de la situation
actuelle c'est que les choix en termes
d'apd et de communication du
gouvernement ont conduit ces dernières
semaines une population française qui
était pourtant une population très en
faveur de la transition écologique a
rejeté cette transition du fait de ses
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat
d'une grande partie des français au
quotidien et ça ça c'est des choix qui
sont catastrophiques parce qu'on abrite
des français qu'ils étaient prêts à
modifier leur comportement a essayé
d'accélérer pour accompagner dans leur
choix de tous les jours la transition
écologique à qui on impose finalement
par un principe de réalité une baisse de
leur pouvoir d'achat lié au fait que
ceux qui doivent pour aller travailler
utiliser leur voiture ne s'en sortent
plus parce qu'ils vont perdre la grande
banque a maintenant 60 sur les lieux au
1er janvier
la réponse de l'augmentation asus
qualité politique elle existe
pas par une tante la loterie c'est une
goutte d'eau c'est une goutte d'eau mais
c'est pas un c'est l'augmentation des
risques et au 1er janvier 2018 qui a
fait qu'ils se sont réveillés neuf mois
après le problème c'est que 20 euros ou
même 5 euros dans le pouvoir d'achat le
porte-monnaie chaque mois des plus
modestes et peut être c'est que les
panneaux et le problème c'est que le
gouvernement considère que c'est sans
doute mieux vaut alors que c'est la
capacité à faire vous mangez ses enfants
pendant une semaine pour certains
pendant que les jours ça suffit pas les
faire rêver à les projeter vers l'avenir
à comprendre pourquoi aujourd'hui on
exige des sacrifices qu'ils soient
riches ou pauvres parce que non car ils
sont là pour payer des impôts et
beaucoup d'impôts moi je fais partie des
riches je paye les dizaines de milliers
d'euros d'impôts tous les ans j'en suis
content
ravi mais j'aimerais aussi tentants
qu'on manque on veut qu'on me dise la
direction que ça va prendre c'est à dire
que quand je vois qu'à la fin de l'année
on continue de voter des budgets
déficitaires je me dis je je mets de
l'argent dans un trou perdu et ça
continue dans d'été et mes enfants et
tout ce qui est autour de moi et puis et
donc on manque d'un projet de société le
projet de société c'est celui de ça
rappelle des années 80 celui de françois
mitterrand évidemment qui s'est terminée
très vite deux ans après avec la
politique de rigueur budgétaire qui a
été mise en place par le gouvernement
fait du ca l'époque mais aujourd'hui on
manque d'une vision d'un projet de
société emmener les gens vers quelque
part et chirac a eu ce défaut hollande
sarkozy macro on espérait les six
premiers mois de son mandat
et voilà qui la veille avait il y avait
quand même quelque chose il y avait un
discours mais il ya trop de discours il
ya trop de verbe et du coup les gens n'y
comprennent rien aujourd'hui a commencé
sur le thème du populisme sur lequel
hier il est revenu en se disant les
mains de populiste forme d'ajustement en
parler on a ce court extrait c'était
hier emmanuel macron devant les maires
vous savez l'association des maires de
france qui est en ce moment en congrès
ça se passait à l'elysée c'est très bref
mais écoutez bien nous sommes des vrais
populiste nous sommes avec le peuple
tous les jours en effet pour travailler
ensemble tout ça me fait confiance
non mais à mener on utilise le terme
populisme à tout va pendant pendant six
mois pour la vilipender le populisme et
c'est sans savoir très bien ce que
représente ce qui se cache derrière ce
concept un peu plus et on parle même de
les propos populistes et pillèrent edit
ah non mais moi aussi je suis populiste
c'est un jeu de mots on comprend le
second degré mais je pense je pense qu'à
force de moins que vous n'ayez d'un
secours le jeune évolution dans le noir
est un jeu de mots ccc c'est un clin
d'oeil c'est un clin d'oeil mais sur des
thèmes qu'il a lui-même diaboliser et un
mot qu'il a sur utilisé par un certain
temps on peut plus se permettre quand on
est président de vue qu'ils m'en passer
le champagne président alors non on ne
voit pas débat on parle d eau puisque
c'est notre sujet non mais c'est
intéressant parce que comme il s'incline
contre progressive
ça fait l'ailé ça fait le lien avec
notre sujet suivant celui des élections
européennes alors le dîner n'est pas
longtemps resté secret y avait donc
quelques huiles autour de la table le
président avait invité entre autres les
deux anciens premiers ministres alain
juppé jean pierre raffarin ya des voix
philippe il y avait aussi françois
bayrou jean yves le drian pierre
moscovici entre autres alors
l'invitation c'était pour parler des
européennes
parmi les convives donc alain juppé qui
dès la fin octobre c'était en quelque
sorte invité à l'élysée écoutez le il
faut que tous ceux qui croient que
l'europe est notre avenir et non pas
notre passé que c'est une chance et non
pas une contrainte se réunissent des
peaux tendues autour du président gros
indépendamment des clivages politiques
bien sûr
gilles sept matches à cette idée de
référendum de plus en plus on voit le
avancé l'idée que ça va être un
référendum pour ou contre l'europe en
tout cas c'est le sco emmanuel macron
veut installer une tromperie sur la
marchandise là oui parce que enfin on
veut essayer de nous faire croire que
les ex des prochaines élections
européennes
d'ailleurs c'est à chaque fois nous
refait le coup ce serait d'un côté ce
qui serait pour l'europe et de l'autre
ceux qui seraient les anti européens
mais c'est pas du tout ça le débat le
aujourd'hui je pense que le pire ennemi
de l'europe aujourd'hui c'est l'europe
elle-même
je pense que la construction européenne
telle qu'elle se fait c'est à dire
jour aller dans le même sens c'est à
dire libre circulation du marché le
business libre circulation des capitaux
la fin des services publics etc etc
cette direction là c'est celle là qui
suscite de plus en plus de rejet dans un
certain nombre de pays donc présenté le
débat comme d'un côté les pro européens
de l'autre les antilles non c'est pas
vrai ce n'est pas du tout ça le dépenser
vous allez pas ne pas être d'accord avec
jeux smadja sur le côté ultra libérale
de l'europe et ultralibéral non je crois
pas allé presque trop administrative est
trop pas assez et pas assez libérale
amont avec mackenzie au pardon mais en
revanche je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est que j'étais lisible complètement
illisibles et et si l'europe ait aussi
peu populaire c'est commencé dans les
années 80 parce que le capitalisme
français a été réformée par françois
mitterrand et qui en appelait au peuple
et qui disait je ne peux pas faire
autrement c'est parce que c'est la
commission européenne qui m'oblige à
réformer l'économie française
on a fermé la sidérurgie etc enfin pas
répéter l'histoire met donc cette europe
elle a été utilisée par les présidents
successifs a commencé votre part par
françois mitterrand pour réformer l'état
français un tant soit peu pas assez
d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu mais
aujourd'hui c'est illisible mais cette
cette europe là il faut la démonter il
faut recommencer à zéro
je suis persuadé on a commencé par
l'ordre de l'économie on aurait dû
commencer par l'europe de la politique
puis ensuite il ya 27 états on aurait dû
se contenter de conçu en europe à 12 ou
à 15 et de la consolider politiquement
avant de l'élargir évident que cette
europe là il faut la démonter nos divers
nar non mais il faut recommencer à zéro
il faut tout il faut neuf on a compris
de l'apathie des demandes et la ville
prenne plus je pense qu'il faut il faut
redonner du sens à ce qu'est la
construction européenne
ou pourquoi on a une union de 27 états
pour quoi faire et surtout pourquoi
faire pour qui c'est la grande île est
trop tard il est trop tard s'essayer à
péril en la demeure
la maison brûle ce qui est en train de
faire emmanuel macron en dix ans d'un
côté il y à moi et tous ceux qui seront
derrière moi alors j'aime beaucoup le
dîner avec un à juppé jean pierre
raffarin ce une manière disons
particulière de renouveler la vie
politique comme avait dit qu'on avait
promis de le faire
emmanuel macron c'est le nouveau monde à
l'ancienne mais outre outre sa emmanuel
macron de jouer à un jeu extrêmement
dangereuse c'est à dire on ne peut pas
dire en tant que président moi je suis
la voix européenne et tous ceux qui sont
derrière moi seront les pro-européens et
tous les autres sont les anti européens
puisque 1
il y aura des résultats ces élections
européennes et il donnera l'impression
que peut-être plus la moitié des
français sont anti europe 1 ce qui n'est
pas une réalité et surtout ce qu'on
attend d'un président la république est
ce qu'on attend d'un parti aujourd'hui
au pouvoir la république en marche c'est
qu'ils donnent leur vision de ce qu'est
un projet européen au service des
peuples s'il porte un projet européen au
service des peuples et il faut un
véritable sens à ce projet en termes de
solidarité ce qu'on veut une europe des
solidarités ce qu'on veut une europe de
la protection sociale est ce qu'on veut
une europe du libéralisme économique
comme à présent ou une europe qui
portent d'autres types de projets ce
qu'on veut une europe de la défense
c'est pas le moment de dire c'est trop
tard c'est ça aussi la marque sur le
côté justement
le coût politique une liste allant de
alain juppé à la gauche
c'est un coup mine de rien il reproduit
c'est la question qu'on pose
il reproduit un peu le côté du casse la
baraque en 2017 une liste soutenue ou
composé d'alain juppé premier ministre
en 1995 l'homme de les retournements 4
kg nous a déjà la jeunesse raffarin
c'est déjà le lieu quand même le
monsieur nobody dire personne ne le
connaissait quand il est devenu premier
ministre personne sans rappel depuis
qu'il est parti de matignon après vous
avez françois bayroux franchement est-ce
que emmanuel macron ne cesse de dire
qu'il est là pour réformer une france
qu'il n'a pas été pendant 30 ans et nous
met en tête d'affiche trois des
principaux hommes politiques qu'on fait
la france de ces trente dernières années
franchement est-ce qu'on va donner envie
aux français de construire l'europe de
lutter contre le populisme
quelle que soit sa définition en mettant
ces trois têtes d'affiché sur le devant
de la scène en tête de gondole
franchement je ne pense pas c'est
totalement contradictoire comme discours
et je pense que c'est totalement
repoussoir est pour et pour finir par
rapport à ce que vous dit juste avant
oui peut-être qu'il faudrait une autre
europe et ça ça ld la beauté du débat
qui va permettre à chaque français de se
déterminer
mais on voit à quel point il coûte cher
et c'est difficile de quitter cette
europe si si imparfaite soit elle on le
voit avec les britanniques étaient
probablement les moins européen l'union
européenne le coût politique et
économique pour eux de noël qui tire à
l'européenne voilà ils nous proposent un
projet de transition qui est tout sauf
une sortie l'union européenne puisque
c'est la continuité de l'existant qui ne
voudront qu'il ne voulait plus donc on
voit qu'on a beau critiquer cette europe
même contre la critique c'est
difficilement qu'il doit quitter
quelques réactions ap ap les internautes
ont la priorité je ne me rappelle pas
assez souvent
alors d'abord la réponse à notre
question la question a été posée en ces
termes la stratégie d' emmanuel macron
de créer un axe central fort de
pro-européens de moscovici à juppé est
elle la bonne vous l'êtes ce que disent
ils oui vous avez % à répondre que non
c'est pas la bonne stratégie si je nous
dit la stratégie de
mâcon c'est moi ou les extrêmes olympe
emmanuel macron n'arrête pas de faire
peur il est clivant et de plus en plus
c'est anti mac
les français ne sont pas tous sortis eux
ils sont anti macron c'est différent
gilles smadja emmanuel macron a été élu
en 2010 est à la faveur d'un duel avec
le front national et il a été largement
élu pourquoi parce que les français dans
leur grande majorité ne voulait pas de
l'extrême droite au pouvoir et ne
veulent toujours pas d'ailleurs et donc
évidemment il sait très bien que ça
c'est le schéma idéal pour lui c'est le
schéma politique idéal pour lui se
retrouver à chaque fois face à l'extrême
droite et il a cultivé il continue de
cultiver cette dualité entre entre moi
et l'extrême droite entre nous il ya
bigard rien et donc évidemment il
entretient sa et il espère sans doute
que ce scénario soit vonnas allait alors
justement c'est la droite la poutre elle
travaille aussi pour reprendre une
expression maintenant un peu consacrée
on va écouter nicolas dupont aignan
président de debout la france vous allez
voir il explique en quoi il fait appel à
marine le pen pour ces élections est
également à laurent wauquiez en
l'écoutant je considère que la crée des
problèmes français est à strasbourg et à
bruxelles et qu'il faut changer cette
europe
je lui dis j'y vais soutenez mois elle
ne veut pas je dis aussi à monsieur
wauquiez
parce que vous savez je ne changerai
jamais d'avis il faut une grande
coalition de gens qui pensent pareil à
la fois des électeurs de marine et des
électeurs devant voquer et j'y arriverai
un jour peut-être pas moi peut-être
d'autres mais en tout cas on ne gagnera
et on ne sera majoritaire que si on sait
monsieur d'effacer nos différences à 4
kg sur le côté à droite aussi on cherche
à élargir et à trouver une liste plus
plus large oui que le socle dupont
aignan celui de 1 allan effectivement l
intérêt que clad du côté de nicolas
dupont aignan il ya une volonté de faire
une liste puissante et de faire un
chiffre avec nice puissante de
souverainistes du côté des manuels
macron il ya la tentation de rejouer le
couple 2017 mais pour répondre
clairement à la question dont il
n'arriva pas l'euro jusqu'en 2017
il s'est fait élire sur une promesse de
résultats ça fait un an et demi il
atteint peint ses résultats donc il
pourra pas rejouer le coup d'une
promesse de résultats possibles à
poussive l'avenir une vraie question
aussi à gauche
est-ce qu'on va avoir une capacité à
gauche à avoir une liste de
rassemblement plutôt que 3,4 liste
totalement éclaté ici la gauche par la
gauche qui va disons or elle est fille
par éclater en une deux trois quatre
listes parti socialiste europe écologie
les verts génération la gauche va vers
une catastrophe
dans son discours et son positionnement
par rapport à la question européenne
justement la question écologique qui va
être là dessus que tant de maquereaux on
a bien sûr affirme ainsi avec un alain
juppé un joker avant et la question
écologique
on le sait aussi ça va être au centre et
c'est toujours aux fins et souvent au
sein des élections européennes a
fortiori nicolas hulot est ce soir
l'invité de l'émission politique sur
france 2 il peut faire sans hulot
emmanuel macron bernabeu
r oui oui définitivement la page est
tournée
je pense bien sûr je pense et en même
temps on sait très bien que ça tend
enfin on regarde ça de près de l'autre
côté de la marche
oui vive attention je pense qu'il est
temps pour savoir comment ça parler
tranquillement france 2 pour regarder
une émission politique avec nick alors
vous avez peut-être réseau en tout cas
du point de vue des internautes du
figaro parce qu'à la question qu'on vous
posez regrettez-vous le retrait de la
vie politique de nicolas hulot vous êtes
c'est donc la question de la sondage 80%
à aller dans l'émission politique c'est
être en retrait de la vie politique
un mois et demi après sa désertion du
gouvernement de parenthèse comprend
également qu'il faut lire comme le
retrait du gouvernement auquel cas oui
bah oui effectivement il ya tout ce qui
se fait comme tout pressé depuis
conforte cette décision alors passer à
un tout autre sujet donc celui de
léonard de vinci c'est un sujet qui a
été dévoilée ce matin dans les pages
culture du figaro
les italiens en effet pourrait refuser
de nous prêter des tableaux des oeuvres
du maître de la renaissance pour une
exposition qui est prévue l'an prochain
au louvre à l'occasion du 500e
anniversaire de sa mort
alors c'est une sous secrétaire d'état
italienne à la culture qui s'est soudain
réveillée en dix ans les français ne
peuvent pas tout avoir léonard et
italiens il est seulement morts en
france alors vous n'êtes pas refaire la
table au graphique denard de vinci c'est
pas le propos mais en tout cas les
relations diplomatiques entre paris et
rome n'était pas au beau fixe ça risque
de ne rien arranger on peut prendre la
faire à la légère on peut en sourire
mais en même temps ça peut être sérieux
c'est inquiétant cette politisation de
quelque chose qui était celle
auriculaire la bergère parce que je
trouve que
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs sur un
premier dossier industriel quand il est
arrivé au pouvoir il s'est opposé sita
lien est là quand il a commencé à leur
faire la leçon enfin c'est le côté over
vous nous donner l'exemple
c'est un pays que j'aime bien qui est
vraiment un allié et un ami de toujours
de la france connait c'est madame lucia
bourgogne n'est pas non non je la
connais pas du tout mais bon j'ai à
défendre les italiens et nos relations
avec l'italie qui est un pays d'ailleurs
une des premières destinations
touristiques des français avec la
turquie même si la turquie aujourd'hui
6é bon tome on peut trouver que c'est le
caylar c'est à la maladresse macro nien
répond-il maladresse voilà une politesse
italienne évidemment mais je trouve ça
très dommage était en italie encore
récemment et les italiens ne comprennent
pas la manière dont emmanuel macron leur
parle et parle alors dirigeants y
compris celles vie ni d'ailleurs il faut
pas oublier que en matière d'immigration
notamment les italiens ont été
extrêmement accueillants malgré tout ils
ont accueilli des centaines de milliers
de migrants sans que l'europe ne les
aident et nous nous sommes à guy moins
de 20000 donc les de les donner des
leçons à des pays amis au sein de
l'union européenne comme le fait manuel
macron je ne comprends pas alors je sais
que c'est un bon gars il y avait aussi
un message interne c'était un sentiment
de la ligue 7 euros je connais bien m'a
d'abord gonzoni colucci je suis
intéressé à elle quand elle est arrivée
au pouvoir
ll est une diplômée de l'académie des
arts de bologne et et elle sait de quoi
elle parle
moi je trouve ça ahurissant comme prise
de position de la part quelqu'un qui
connaît les arts et la culture
je trouve ça ahurissant alors elle est
membre d'un parti d'extrême droite la
ligue du nord et donc c'est pas tout à
fait étonnant elle apprit qu elle
applique à la culture le principe de la
préférence nationale
mais c'est totalement uris ans parce que
les lits pour l'italie léonard de vinci
canaletto c'est véronèse c'est un
patrimoine extraordinaire et ils
devraient ils sont fiers ils doivent
être fiers quand des dizaines de
millions de personnes à travers le monde
se précipite encore aujourd'hui pour
aller voir des expositions
vinci canaletto véronèse et tous ces
peintres italiens qui nous ont laissé un
patrimoine le fabuleux et donc dire non
non non ça nous appartient c'est à nous
il est italien dont il sortira pas d'ici
mais c'est complètement ahurissant comme
prise de position de la part de
ministres la culture tant qu'allié elle
devrait interdire à gianluigi bouffonne
de rester 15e but du paris saint germain
parce que c'est un monument historique
casillas est plus fine c'est à dire que
oui c'est une instrumentalisation une
politisation la culture de la lecture
elle met sa prise de position est
beaucoup plus fine c'est à dire qu'elle
vit attention les français veulent tous
or nous on a notamment dans les offices
de florence trois tableaux qui n'ont
jamais été sorti donc c'est sans doute
compliqué de les amener jusqu'au lourds
comme nous nos conservateurs du louvre
nous vient ce sont des tendances et
c'est ces querelles et de faire bouger
la joconde pour l'amener dans telle ou
telle est la question est de savoir
fille alemagna les déclarations
politiques après il ya des années il
essaie de mettre aussi en avant des
raisons techniques et elle essaie aussi
de mettre en avant je vais négocier un
deal qui a été fait avec la france en
2007 sur un échange ou d'oeuvres entre
raphaël et léonard de vinci pour aller
pour aller plus loin mais cette
politisation oui elle est liée au fait
que la france ces derniers mois les
dirigeants français ont joué la carte de
l'humiliation et de je méprise et je
regarde de haut les x et les dirigeants
italiens ça s'est vu sur un certain
nombre de dossiers économiques
ça s'est vu également quand on met
matteo salvini en avant comme le
repoussoir dans un clip de campagne
gouvernementale pour appeler à voter aux
élections européennes mais italien loin
c'est mal pris et on dit qu'il avait mal
pris c'est à dire qu'un moment donné
quelles que soient les positionnements
politiques des uns des autres sur des
partenaires européens majeurs ya une
réserve avoir de relations notamment à
avoir pour pas que la situation se
dégrade et ensuite oui ce qui est
dangereux avec cette politisation là sur
cette question là c'est c'est dangereux
de commencer à jouer les arts de la
musique nationale de vinci et italiens
et alors là on va lui répondre mais nos
léonard de vinci est mort en france
et en plus si les pays tallien et les
toscans donc on ressort la création de
là
à l'époque c'est à dire grand chose
comme ça j'aurai avoir une petite pensée
pour course avec saint brice et le clos
lucé
on peut il a passé les dernières
vacances
absolument et oui un superbe musée
l'honneur de massy de marque vous êtes
plutôt à dire que bouffonne doit
retourner en italie puisque c'est quoi
votre position sur ce sujet cheap à 2
comme vous l'avez peut-être un sur
l'autre aspect qui n'est pas le même
sujet mais quand même c'est ça faisait
l'objet d'un autre article dans le
figaro et dans d'autres journaux 7
rapports de deux spécialistes
universitaires qui disent on doit
restituer une bonne partie des oeuvres
d'art africaine aux pays d'afrique où
ils ont été pris essentiellement pendant
la période coloniale entre 1880 et 1960
c'est pas rien parce que c'est près de
100 mille objets qui sont venus du mali
du tchad du cameroun pour l'essentiel
d'ailleurs qui sont au quai branly
marque vous avez le temps de réfléchir
vous avez une idée là aussi sûr parce
que il ya de la politique aussi si on
commence à ouvrir cette boîte de pandore
de dire à l'afrique
retour à l'afrique des objets qui ont
été présents la colonisation
tout est politique oui tout est
politique mais il faut le faire il faut
dire vous donner mon point de vue oui
mais pas forcément celui du journal dans
lequel pleuvent
un point de vue oui oui mon point de vue
oui il faut rendre oui c'est après c'est
tout et 2c de la diplomatie c'est de la
discussion
ce sont les l'art que ce soit léonard de
vinci entre la france à l'italie que
soient les oeuvres d'art africaine entre
la france et le continent africain
notamment la france ses anciennes
colonies
tout est à des armes de la diplomatie
sait pas on peut aller se poser la
question à tout ça l'egypte peut
réclamer et puis la grève depuis ce
qu'elle fait d'ailleurs ce qu'elle fait
oui vu jusqu'à présent ça n'a pas abouti
cela n'empêche pas demander un certain
nombre d'oeuvres d'art majeures que les
musées excusez mon europe 1 avant tout
anglais français allemand ou conserver
pendant des dizaines d'années au nom
d'un principe de musée universel qui
aujourd'hui avec eux c'est à dire dire
mais le monde entier peuvent venir voir
les oeuvres dans nos musées donc nous
allons les garder parce que nous avons
des capacités de conservation des
oeuvres meilleur que les autres pays
savaient que parce que s'il ya la
possibilité de venir voir les oeuvres à
paris mais y aura la possibilité d'aller
voir les ordres au bénin au congo est
ailleurs et on a aujourd'hui à cette
circulation d'experts en conservation
des oeuvres pour que les oeuvres soient
viables préserver en egypte en grèce et
au bénin pour prendre l'exemple d'un
pays africain
et c'est pas une question de vider les
musées on va pas évident et le quai
branly mais rendre un certain nombre
d'oeuvres majeures pour permettre que
dans certains pays il y aussi des musées
qui est une possibilité pour les
habitants de ce pays d'être en contact
direct avec ce qui est leur histoire
culturelle c'est un point c'est un point
majeur et je pense qu'il faut que la
france avance dans ce sens et soit
plutôt porteuse d'une dynamique positive
en ce sens
relève du patrimoine universel et donc
c'est un trait d'union entre les peuples
j'ai pas si on ouvre cette boîte de
pandore je crains qu effectivement ce
soit très rapidement politisé et que
derrière ils étaient indigéniste air
asia dit racialiste et cetera a
finalement une oeuvre d'art africaine
nasa a sa place en afrique et ne peut
être regardée que par les africains et
peut-être que demain si on met ça dans
certains musées ou les interdira aux
blancs parce qu'on dira ce sont des
masques africains
les blancs sont interdits de regarder
ses oeuvres je ne sais pas je dois je
suis interdit donc oui il y en a on
reçoit on en est revenu
heureusement sinon mais justement
gardons ce principes universalistes
voilà après ces traités des oeuvres la
circulation des oeuvres
oui pourquoi pas après malheureusement
on voit bien la guerre en irak
enfin le musée de bagdad étaient
détruits je reviens de beyrouth ils ont
fait un travail formidable et un nouveau
musée national qui est qui est repartie
qui a été reconstruit mais
malheureusement il ya beaucoup d'oeuvres
qui ont disparu voilà c'est compliqué
d'avoir un avis tranché sur la question
c'est difficile mais je me méfie quand
même de la politisation du débat quoi
alors risque moi je crois que les
oeuvres d'art elles sont faites pour
être montrées et pour être vu par le
plus grand nombre
c'est le sens même du rapport qu'on doit
avoir à là aujourd'hui
et là où il ya un vrai problème c'est
que les grandes expositions de peinture
qui circulent aujourd'hui à travers le
monde par exemple
exposition de peintures picasso miro on
envoie des ghana de magnifiques
actuellement à paris basquiat yvonne
chine et ses expositions là aujourd'hui
il ya toute une partie de la planète qui
ne les voit jamais elles ne vont jamais
elle elle emprunte un circuit qui est
toujours le même c'est à dire ce sont
les grandes des grandes capitales et
grandes villes riches des pays
développés et vous avez des continents
entiers qui sont complètement à la
ramasse qui sont complètement laissée de
côté sur l'accès à ces heures là il ya
un vrai problème et vous avez même
aujourd'hui un phénomène encore plus
inquiétant c'est que certains musées de
par exemple des musées argent argent en
argentine les musées et hésitent à
laisser sortir leurs oeuvres pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un risque qu'elle soit
saisie en raison des problèmes
d'endettement
pays c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on va
vers une espèce de 2,2 système qui fait
que trop de gens sont écartés de la sur
les trente dernières années quand même
il ya beaucoup de circulation de breda
reprendre il ya 30 ans quand même là des
grandes expositions
oui oui bien batman en asie ce n'était
pas le cas en asie a 30 ans aujourd'hui
à des gangs alors sur sa position il ya
dix abeba non gillard
ces pays où on peut pas facilement voir
bizarrement en autant de journées
j'essaie d'avoir un visa fois vos
problèmes de visa bernard c'est une
chose au jeu important parce qu'il n'ya
pas la libye qui sont des cailloux à la
guitare et je vais quand même donné le
résultat de la concession sur le sujet
l'italie at elle raison de remettre en
question les prêts accordés au louvre
pour la rétrospective dédiée à léonard
de vinci
vous dites à 52% vous dit que non l
italie a tort c'est bien ça clôt nous
dit la culture doit rester au dessous
dessus pardon de toute division l'art
est un trait d'union entre les peuples
les hommes
ricker car emmanuel macron va nous
fâcher avec tout le monde
cab ronito la culture est un moyen de
défendre des causes et de s'opposer à
des idéologies et
qui ajoute par contre et c'est une
blague
on a rendu valls à l'espagne ça vous
fait rire marque tant mieux un dernier
sujet un peu de temps mais on va quand
même en parler un petit peu alors c'est
cette annonce faite par la garde des
sceaux nicole belloubet hier soir à
l'assemblée elle a dit il faut réformer
l'ordonnancé de 45 leur donnant de 45
c'est ce texte qui régit la justice des
mineurs un texte sensible qui dans
lequel souvent l'idéologie l'emportent
sur le pragmatisme on en parle mais on
regarde d'abord ce qu'a dit la ministre
de la justice
nous devons juger plus vite les mineurs
pour qu'ils prennent conscience de la
gravité de leurs actes lorsque c'est le
cas et nous devons aussi prendre des
mesures qui soient adaptés à chaque
profil de ces jeunes délinquants sans
angélisme et sans démagogie c'est
pourquoi je vous annonce que dans le
cadre de la loi pour la réforme de la
justice le gouvernement sollicitera du
parlement une habilitation pour réformer
l'ordonnancé de 1945 par la création
d'un code de justice pénale des mineurs
jugés plus vite les mineurs vous
applaudissez dès demain celle ce matin
le choix de le choix de faire cette
réforme par ordonnance est quand même
étonnant parce que c'est un enjeu de
sion c'est normal ça mais répondait déjà
sur la question il faut juger trop vite
est-ce que c'est du gpcg plus vite je ne
sais quoi je vois pas un professionnel
la justice par contre ce que je sais
c'est comme à peu près tous les
syndicats aujourd'hui notamment
ce qu'il faut surtout c'est faire en
sorte que les décisions du qui sont
prises aujourd'hui pour la justice des
enfants et des adolescents soient
appliquées ce qui n'est pas du tout le
cas
c'est à dire exécution aujourd'hui vous
avez un phénomène qui existe dans des
dizaines de tribunaux en france c'est
qu'entre le moment où un juge prend une
mesure concernant un enfant ou un
adolescent elle au moment où cette
mesure elle est effective il peut se
passer trois mois ci soit vous rendez
compte
à bobigny où la situation est absolument
dramatique
les 15 juges du tribunal pour enfants et
quinze ont signé ensemble c'est très
rare un texte pour dire nous sommes
devenus les juges de mesures fictives
c'est quand même parce que parce que on
mesure par exemple de que l'enfant soit
déplacé dans tel endroit etc
il faut attendre 18 mois ouais pour que
l'éducateur ne comprends pas c'est à
dire que le mineur
qu'a commis un acte délictueux ne
comprends pas qu on le sanctionne du
mois après parce qu'il est déjà
quelqu'un d'autre d'ailleurs à l'époque
elle a raison et nicole v groupe est de
dire il faut réformer l'ordonnancé de 45
oui sans doute mais le problème ne
réside pas là le prêt mais il réside
dans l'éducation dans le soutien aux
familles résidant enfin voila je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire durcir les peines aussi parce que
l'exemption de minorité aujourd'hui
c'est diviser par deux la peine quand on
a entre 16 et 18 ans donc ça supposerait
aussi d'aggraver ces peines ou
finalement de garder la peine qu'ils
étaient c'est pas possible car il les
magistrats n'ont toujours c'est une
possibilité ça peut plus donc voila moi
ce qui me frappe c'est que
la plupart de ces enfants délinquants
prédélinquants sont souvent de familles
monoparentales avec des femmes qui ne
verse auquel on ne verse pas les
pensions alimentaires les maris ou les
ex mari ne verse pas l'essentiel des
pensions alimentaires ou les ex
compagnon est en train de faire un sud
sur la pauvreté qu'on vous cache et deux
ou trois millions de familles
monoparentales avec des femmes qui
serait ce qu'en dit traiter leur job
pour garder leurs gosses pour par les
emmener à l'école le matin et c'est un
vrai une vraie désespérance donc la
justice ne suffit pas c'est à dire s'est
il faut de l'accompagnement tous les
plans sur tous les plans et je me
rappelle d'ailleurs à mayotte j'avais vu
un colonel qui commande est une école de
la deuxième chance dans lesquels on met
ces prêts délinquants pour essayer de le
remettre dans le droit chemin et musées
nerfs un peu désabusé mise et c'est fou
parce que finalement pendant trente ans
on a démoli des valeurs morales
trimballer notamment est véhiculée par
la chose militaire
et aujourd'hui c'est à nous qu'on ne
rentrent et part et la société et de
remettre les les enfants dans le droit
chemin en leur donnant un peu le sens
des autres et la discipline sais pas si
vous avez vu général de villiers
d'ailleurs dont on n'est pas couché
samedi dernier il était formidable
aghet temps mis l'année c'est marrant
parce que ils étaient accueillis
christine angot et et laurent wauquiez
enfin avait beaucoup de considération
pour lui ça a répété le caiap l'attend
j'ai envoyé une petite révolution
culturelle et morale c'est quand même la
moindre des choses à voir un peu de
considération si on regarde son parcours
son regard sont parfois mignot mais
quand on sait ce que la gauche est anti
militariste ya 20 ou 30 ans démolissant
spéciaux disciplinés
faire l'émission formés mais j'aimerais
vous entendre aussi sur le côté je me
suis nicolas sarkozy on croit disait un
jeune de 16 ans aujourd'hui on était à
2018 mais ne ressemble pas à celui de 45
donc il ya matière à réformer oui il
faut réformer cette ordonnance tous les
professionnels le disent d'abord parce
que c'est pas du tout un totem c'est un
texte qui a été bougés près de 40 fois
aujourd'hui c'est un millefeuille il
faut mettre de la clarté il faut
reprendre ce texte il faut reprendre ce
texte avec pour moi deux principes à
respecter le premier c'est la recherche
de réponses éducatives
il faut construire des parcours pour ces
jeunes pour les aider à sortir à ne pas
rentrer plus tôt dans des parcours des
délinquances il faut que des sanctions
soient des sanctions qui ait un sens
éducatif
ce qui veut dire des sanctions qu'ils
soient appliquées rapidement et ce qui
veut dire qu'il ya un accompagnement
vraiment des jeunes pour qui il ya un
sens qu'ils comprennent
là où a été la faute et pourquoi ils ne
doivent pas rêver 17 fautes ça c'est un
point qui me paraît essentiel dans la
réforme qu'il faut conduire
le deuxième point qui me paraît
essentielle c'est que oui il faut garder
le principe de l'atténuation de la
responsabilité en fonction de la justice
attention sans les verts nicole
belloubet faisons cette réforme sans
angélisme et sans démagogie non plus un
pas essentiel
attention parce que la démagogie elle
arrive très souvent deux extrêmes le
côté sexy rapidement sur ce sujet mais
je tiens quand même à souligner mon
accord avec ce point de forme
essentielle c'est un texte qui aurait dû
être débattu au parlement et pas
seulement à dakar avec la voix annonce à
voir comment c'est pas et pas à terre ou
au coeur de l'ampleur du sujet un
dernier mot peut-être marque sur le
sujet
qu'est ce qui vous paraît le plus urgent
parce que on dit non je vous pose la
question aussi parce que la justice est
un des secteurs où on dit toujours il ya
peu de moyens il faut augmenter les
budgets c'est le parent pauvre des
budgets là c'est un secteur où
effectivement il ya peut-être urgence
il ya urgence et de toute façon tous les
efforts budgétaires qui seront faits en
faire de la justice seront jamais
suffisant parce qu on part de tellement
bas qu'il faudrait il faudrait
complètement révolutionné l'ordre des
choses pour faire en sorte que vous
parlez avec bobigny effectivement c'est
un scandale national d'état ce qui se
passe là-bas pour inverser l'ordre des
choses donc emmanuel macron lui mais un
milliard mais un milliard de plus sur le
quinquennat sur le ministre de la
justice c'est beaucoup c'est 20% en plus
ça sera pas suffisant et tout de toute
façon quand on voit la pauvreté la
misère dans laquelle la justice ait
répondu en france se rend en france
chérie on est les bras m'en tombent
alors ceux de nos internautes en tout
cas leur voix on va aller on va
l'entendre faut-il créer comme le
souhaite nicolas beloou bea code de la
justice pénale pour les mineurs
en gros s'il faut il réformer
l'ordonnancé 45 oui à 70% si je nous dit
je suis mitigé un gamin de 14 ans n'a
rien à faire en prison
et il ajoute un ado délinquance ouvre
souvent d'une carence familiale nicole
elle n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
enfin en tout cas elle dit nous sommes
trop laxiste avec les mineurs
délinquants
voilà pour ce soir en tout cas sur le
ces différents sujets en un mot on a on
n'a même pas eu son nom on a dépassé mes
pronostics pour pour la coupe davis
marque parce que je sorte vous êtes
frustré de pas avoir parlé du sujet la
france sur terre battue face au de deux
membres du top ten croate ça va être
très dur mais on va gagner d'accord pas
d'accord
gilles c'est la dernière coupe davis
dans telle qu'on la connaît dans cette
formule qui est magnifique et qui
malheureusement va être supprimé donc
oui c'est normal
voilà exactement ben voilà donc willy
yannick noah est capable d'emmener
encore la france au bout merci beaucoup
à tous les cas merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis vous avez rendez vous
demain avec guillaume roquette pour un
nouveau point de vue
[Musique]
à